you cannot live well I'll be agreed in a
world that is swiftly approaching
combined crisis of the shortage of
resources of the decline of arable land
of the destruction of its forests of the
changing of the atmosphere and so on so
we really are at a turning point and we
have to do it so the question now is can
we do it without you know living
returning to some more primitive less
comfortable less secure life and the
answer is we sure can because the more
we learn about how life works the more
we learn how we fit into this
environment and how we can maintain and
then reduce our numbers and our impact
on the planet and the more we learn with
sustainable uses of energy and you and
didn't apply that then we will find
ourselves in a much more advanced
civilization that does better thinks
better lives better and longer in and I
was less of a less of pressure on the
rest of the planet in other word with
less of a footprint of an ecological
footprint that's our aim sustainable
development with increasing quality of
life if you want to measure the say the
bottom line the the the the profit of
human endeavors by quality of life then
I think it would be very wise to do so
and I see note no prospect that would
halt a steady improvement of life while
we settle
so now we've gotta settle down now as a
species in this century before we wreck
this planet